qurani app not only does it encourage
you to read it tells you how many verses
you've read how many pages you read how
long you've been on it and best of all
the hasanah counter download the qurani
app now i'm looking guys so a muslim
brother made some kind of a comment on
reddit and ksi was going through it and
reacting to it and he came across my
video where his bodyguard is walking in
the background now i'm not doing this
video just for that because okay as i
mentioned because it's famous i'll be
honest with you i don't uh really care
in that aspect i don't mean to sound
rude i'm not doing this to get cloud i
always got real
no genuinely this is profound because
it's as if allah is giving ksi
a sign and i'm not saying the sign is
through me but watch this inshallah
let's watch together i found your
bodyguard steve in a random video huh
where's steve steve
steve
when allah subhanahu want's good for
someone or you know he's sending him
signs you need to understand that works
in different ways because me my myself
personally when i was looking to islam
one of the biggest factors that made me
come to islam was what the scientific
miracles in the quran i'll be honest
with you that was one of the things that
made me come to islam however when i
came to islam and the whole scientific
miracle thing got debunked and when i
mean debunked it's not because the
atheist had some kind of a point no it's
because as muslims we were reading into
the text and describing all this talks
about that that talks about that oh
no where who gave the authority for us
to interpret it text in that way it was
our fault that re that shocked me a
little bit i was like how could it be
but then i realized i said you know what
i don't care let's suppose that's the
kids no no problem because our yardstick
is not science the point i'm trying to
make here is allah can bring someone to
islam for reasons other than that for
example a muslim
man or a christian man or whoever he
wants to marry a muslim girl so he's
like oh except islam deep inside he
doesn't believe in it he comes and he
sees the truth and he states like the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him he
would give things to the arabs yeah in
like war beauty for example camels money
etc why to soften their hearts towards
islam so that when they come to islam
and see the truth they stay it's the
same thing with me for ksi to open a
video and his bodyguard happens to walk
in the background in one of my videos or
whoever it may be that is not a chance
we do not believe in chances that is a
sign now i would advise ksi please send
this video to him inshallah okay i don't
want him to react to et cetera i don't
like i don't want nothing from him but
goodness and guidance for him in the
hereafter
to watch that video in itself because it
was a good uh video but also i really
really want him if he can guys to watch
the video to react to the video from
talk islam which is talks a powerful
video where a lot of people have reacted
to please please get him to at least
watch that video because i believe he's
so profound and he'll be blown away from
it and i just want to end it in a
nutshell guys
without not saying much but allah said
in the quran and if ksi if you're
watching this please please please your
creation the way you're created there is
a purpose it's impossible my shirt my
watch my jeans my socks have a purpose
have a design and have a designer it's
impossible for you as a magnificent
creation like all of us to be created
without a purpose or to believe in the
creator that gives no purpose and just
created us impossible look at what allah
says in the quran and i'll wrap with
these guys inshallah and please please
bombard and send us to ksi to watch and
watch the video that i'm talking about
what is
when the sky splits when the sky will
spit open and when the stars will fall
away and when the seas burst forth and
when the graves will spill out we're all
going to come with their judgment then
each soul will know what it is send
forth and what is left behind good deeds
and the things that i could have done
all humanity what has made you forget
what has made you uh emboldened against
your lord like made you forget your
generous lord who created you fashioned
you and perfected you in design molding
you in whatever form he willed this is
the message of the quran and i swear to
god
ksi was watching this i swear to god i
came to islam 10 years ago there is not
a single book on this planet earth that
has evidences the miracles the
prophecies like the quran is preserved
that's all i have to say i ask allah to
guide ksi to islam inshallah um and we
ask for the best it is happening
hereafter uh for all of us send this
video to him till next time assalamu
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh